imagine a world without fossil fuels
none at all
[Music]
imagine a world where you never need to
smell the fumes of a passing car bus or
truck and where traffic noise is
massively reduced imagine a world
powered by something you can't touch
which will be abundant for billions of
years imagine a world where every single
home has electricity no matter how far
it is from the grid that's the future
beyond fossil fuels imagine government's
no longer needing to subsidize fossil
fuel production or spend fortunes
protecting their underground fuel
sources pipes and transmission lines
trillions of taxpayer dollars are freed
up smog and greenhouse gases plummet
public health improves this healthy
future is closer than you think our
energy system is undergoing an
unstoppable transformation the
coal-fired power industry that took a
century to build is being rapidly
replaced by Sun and wind power forces of
nature which cannot be dug out of the
ground or sold on commodity markets in
this totally fossil fuel free world
electricity belongs to everyone
is homegrown in the true sense bringing
power to the 1.3 billion people who are
currently inexcusably without it the
Paris climate agreement bound nations of
the world to work peacefully for a
fossil fuel free economy but we need to
move fast we must harness the power of
the Sun and work at the speed of light
our collective mission is to bend the
curve of emissions now so that renewable
energy outcompetes fossil fuels as the
best new source of energy in all markets
around the world by 2020 so let's thank
fossil fuels for all they have done
their contribution to humanity has been
nothing short of extraordinary
however now that we understand the
dangers and the side effects and have
exciting everlasting alternatives it is
time to retire them front o the journey
to our fossil fuel free future is the
most exciting the most innovative the
most necessary the most inclusive and
far-reaching global transformation we
have ever seen this is the answer to so
many challenges in the world the energy
nutopia the only question now is how
quickly can we get there thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon